when you think about something like the
all-in podcast i don't think any of you
would uh position yourself as a
journalist but obviously there's a lot
of people who consume that context they
want to learn they want to actually get
information as to what's happening in
current events
how different is that actually than some
of these media companies where people
are you know hiding behind or uh kind of
positioning themselves as journalists
like is it now everyone on the
internet's a content creator or is there
still a big difference in your opinion
well i think we have this epidemic of
fake experts you know people who claim
some sort of expert status but really as
a way to shut down the debate like oh
you don't know what you're talking about
i'm an expert so just listen to me
um i think if you're
an entrepreneurial type of person
that sort of appeal to authority has
never worked you know founders
always start from having an idea that's
either contrarian or no one's really
thought of before and this idea that oh
i need to listen to what somebody else
says automatically
without consulting you know my own um
my own ideas uh my own world view
because they're some sort of expert i
think that's never been compelling to
people in our world
and but that's kind of what you get a
lot of it in the traditional media now i
don't purport to be an expert
i'm just a consumer of information but
what i try to do is go out and research
the topics that we're going to talk
about on the pod
and formulate my own view and synthesize
material from people who i find
compelling or convincing and then i
repackage it in my own way and then
um sort of um
you know sort of uh talk about that so
and then people either like it or they
don't um but but yeah that's that's what
i try to do and how important is it that
you actually have skin in the game i
think another piece of this is like you
know a journalist or a blogger or
whoever uh on the internet opinion
whether it's right or wrong kind of
there's no feedback loop there's no
accountability just move on to the next
you know hot take or prediction versus
the market participant whether it's an
entrepreneur or an investor uh if you're
wrong and you put money behind it you
lose money right and then there is that
kind of feedback loop and so is that
play an important role as well in terms
of the way that you think about the
content that you guys are are producing
yeah certainly when it comes to all the
business topics we do actually have skin
of the game where participants in the
ecosystem we're discussing business
strategies that we ourselves are
implementing
and so there is you know market feedback
on that um and if we're wrong then we
will pay a penalty
you just don't see that you know in the
in general in the news media and there
seems to be no penalty
for being wrong
uh it just seems like we just move on to
the next topic and there's never a
comeuppance for the people who are so
tragically wrong about what the last
issue was
um you know where was the comeuppance
for example for the foreign policy
establishment that got us into the iraq
war and got us into a losing effort in
afghanistan for 20 years i mean these
people are still in the government
there's just no
no heads have rolled even the bosh
withdrawal from afghanistan no heads
rolled for that there's no
accountability so there's so many issues
like that the the lockdowns that we
pursued during covid
um now everybody i think has sort of
admitted that they're wrong there's a
video going around of bill gates
basically saying they didn't work uh so
even the people who were advocating for
them at the time now admit they were
just tragically wrong basically crater
our economy
um didn't stop the virus
where's the comeuppance for the people
who promoted those policies i think
there will eventually will be hopefully
at the ballot box but certainly in the
media they're not holding anybody
accountable yeah well and i would even
argue that many of the people in the
media don't believe that they didn't
work right they still would advocate
that they're important and uh
in some ways that we should still have
some form of of these things um when you
talk about this like
fake expertise or this appeal to
expertise uh it just makes me think of
the time when fauci was doing an
interview and he basically said like i
represent science right right and and uh
that's one example of many i think in
society but like it is important i think
to have people who are not market
participants commentating etc but it
does feel like podcasts twitter and many
of these other forms have let the market
participants now have a voice and in
some cases you know if you look at elon
and some of these folks who have tens of
millions of followers on these platforms
they have a bigger voice than even some
of the media companies i think i saw um
when elon went to go buy twitter i went
and i looked and elon has double the
number of followers on twitter that the
new york times has and twitter does you
know much more revenue than the new york
times does and so like in some way do
you get the new york times is now a
competitor with twitter and if elon owns
twitter like
are you just a billionaire you know are
you employing people at the new york
times as a billionaire to attack other
billionaires and like vice versa like
how do you think about that well i think
that
the traditional media has had a huge
animus towards social networking for
years because social networking
has not only
stolen all these page views and all this
attention and engagement away from them
and and thereby
uh you know turn their analog doll
dollars into digital pennies remember
that that old saying so dramatically
impacted their business model for the
worst but also disintermediated them i
mean the only time i ever go to the new
york times is if somebody who i like
tweets something that's interesting that
links to a new york times article so
the power and influence of these
publications has been dramatically
reduced by social networking and that's
why you've seen
basically this war on social networking
and the the form it takes is basically
these claims
that you know was primarily facebook
last year
uh you know it creates all these harms
on society and therefore we need to
regulate and restrict and censor them
and
you know it's pretty striking that you
see
publications who
were are supposed to be champions of the
first amendment because that's the
principle on which their whole business
is built now
advocating for
censoring and restricting these
platforms yeah um talk to me about uh
the members of the all-in podcast and
the last thing we'll talk about uh do
you and jason like each other are you
guys actually friends
all right
uh i think a lot of people think you're
friends but they listen to the podcast
like man they're always at each other's
throat to some degree um yeah we also
agree on a lot of issues and um you know
the way i i kind of see it so whenever
there's an issue that jason can see with
his own eyes and here with his own ears
so for example
uh san francisco we agree about like
everything that's gone wrong in san
francisco we probably vote the exact
same way you know in elections
and so on but when it comes to things
that are far away
jason relies i think to a great
extent on the traditional news media for
his views and so
on the pod he's going to represent you
know like the brian steltzer opinion or
something
and so this is why we end up getting in
disputes is i'm like dude you're just
repeating the same [ __ ] narrative
that you know we get in all these other
places i have to correct you on that and
then that starts a debate so we do agree
on a lot but that's where things go off
the rails and obviously you're
incredibly kind to him the entire time
as well um when when you think about uh
so many of the people that uh you grew
up in your career right as an
entrepreneur now as an investor uh
they've gone on to do amazing things and
and uh some of them are still very
publicly known and
uh even participate in the podcast all
that uh but many of them also just are
busy building companies and people know
about them but they don't necessarily go
in the media all the time what's your
relationship with like with them i think
a lot of people say like hey there's
this group of folks from the paypal
mafia that are all super super
successful like do you guys have a
secret chat where you're all constantly
talking to each other is it just as
normal friends as anybody else would
have like what does that relationship
look like well there were pre-existing
friendships uh before the paypal mafia
that brought the team together you know
one people the one misconception about
the paper mafia is people think it was
like some sort of very exclusive club
and the reality is we recruited our
friends because nobody else would work
at the company uh you just go back to
1999 it was like much harder than 2000
after the com crash it was much harder
to convince somebody to leave a safe
well-paying job at an investment bank or
management consulting firm or a law firm
to come work at a startup that was still
seen as an incredibly risky thing to do
when i
joined paypal
everyone tried to talk me out of it
including you know my from my parents on
down
um if i hadn't known uh peter thiel and
been friends with him i never would have
taken that risk and so on down the line
so peter recruited people he knew from
stanford max recruited people he knew
from u of i
so um
yeah i mean so there are a lot of
pre-existing friendships and then the
experience of going through
these paypal wars together
um you know
i'd say generally uh
develop those friendships even more now
it's not like we hang out with each
other all the time and it's not like one
monolithic group but we do tend to see
each other from time to time in various
contexts so yeah catch up and
why is it that you all
were friends before like is it just you
happen to all end up at stanford or u of
i or was there some common threat like
what brought you all together because i
think a lot of people look around at
their friend circle like saying college
and they're like man i don't think elon
musk is hanging out here right i don't
think whatever like what brought you all
together what was like the selection
mechanism that you kind of would
attribute uh how you all ended up
together
well so max recruited his um engineering
friends at u of i so i think that was
pretty straightforward and then peter
recruited a number of the people he was
friends with and you know peter had
started had founded the stanford review
which is sort of the conservative
libertarian student newspaper on campus
and i had gone on to become an editor of
that paper several years later so that's
how we met
so there was this libertarian strand to
the founding team and
so
we were all and that was sort of like
this contrarian um
you know
libertarians tend to be not just
contrarian but also sort of um
free market
and so there was a certain sense in
which everybody was cut from
this sort of uh entrepreneurial cloth
now
it's not universally true you know like
uh reed hoffman was not part of the
stanford review in fact he was sort of
on the other extreme he was more liberal
and he still is to this day but he and
peter used to have political debates or
discussions in college and then that's
how reid you know ended up being
recruited by peter so
it's not universally true but there was
something to that that um
the founding team were you know like um
given the sort of the prevailing college
uh the prevailing culture on college
campuses at that time which was sort of
this whole political correctness thing
uh we were rebels against that and i
think that rebel mentality translated
well into becoming founders of
entrepreneurs once we graduated
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time